your thoughts on a one-night stand what
do you think is it harmless is it a big
deal is it which you think
I think it's harmless
for women for women
it's not a lot of people be upset about
that yeah how can you explain why the
woman slept with more than five people
so if she's a virgin on her wedding
night she has an 80 chance of a happy
marriage 80 after 10 years so they did a
study right they basically asked women
how many sexual partners they had before
they got married and if there were
virgins on their what and then they came
back in 10 years and said are you happy
now the women that were virgins in 10
years 80 chance of a happy marriage